often here
um today i'm going to talk about what
really matters in language learning
and this kind of this thought came to me
as i was having lunch just now
and you know i've been
involved now in this language learning
activity
i guess probably about eight or nine
years it all started
when i was 55 so that's 11 years ago and
i decided to really go after learning
cantonese
and i said i guess since that time i've
spent more time and effort on language
learning than just about any other
equivalent 10-year period
and i wrote a book on the subject of
language learning and i think my ideas
about what works
were much more definite before than they
are now
i was much more inclined to say do this
because this is good and this works and
i know it works because it works for me
and i think now i've kind of backed off
that a little bit i mean i still believe
in the things that i think work
because they work for me but i recognize
that
when it comes to language learning the
most important thing
uh
what really matters is
you the learner
you know i have someone on my youtube
channel here come at me and say the only
way to learn is that the military and
diplomat
language schools run by i guess the us
army or whoever
and
you know any other way doesn't work or
something and i said well no i don't
think so i said i think it depends on
the individual if you have a motivated
learner
they will learn anywhere and if the
learner is not motivated they won't
learn
and they came back you don't know what
you're talking about blah blah blah and
i've actually i studied with a number of
diplomats and military people 40 years
ago i don't think the teaching
methods have improved that much
i've seen the products of those systems
i've seen the incredible money that the
canadian federal government wastes on
sending
bureaucrats to language school i heard
of one guy who
was in the canadian aid agency and spent
a whole year on french and then decided
he felt he wasn't quite fluent enough to
be sent to a francophone country so he
was sent to an anglophone country
as an aid officer a fairly senior guy i
presume so a full year salary full-time
study didn't learn the lang french in a
bilingual country like canada didn't
learn it well enough to go and work in a
francophone country um
so you know it all depends on the
individual
it it again relates back to this um
you know i should say i i mean i i'm
sure that at these schools they impose
discipline on you so if you're not
disciplined you need to go to a school
i'm sure they do a lot of drilling
but maybe you know i don't want to sit
in the class and be drilled
uh it might be good but then the problem
with all of those schools is that it
takes away
your own initiative why why are we
learning the language of course if
you're
paid by the army and they say you shall
go and learn a language then you do
whatever they tell you to do
that's understandable
but
if i look at my check for example i'm
sitting there today
i'm reading on my ipad i finished
reading uh an article about
the austro-hungarian empire and learning
a lot of stuff about czech history and
different personalities uh in that
period then i read
an interview
from
the czech radio with someone who was
talking about
who heads up the
institute for the study of totalitarian
regimes in the czech republic and talked
about a number of issues
and i'm reading it and i'm understanding
it and i'm happy i still can't speak
very well i can't speak i haven't spoken
much
but i'm happy so my goals are satisfied
i'm not learning
for someone else i'm learning for me
you know it gets back to this whole
issue of when you're in a classroom and
you read something they ask you to prove
that you understood it
and as ruben alves and anyone that's
into portuguese i recommend that you
google for ruben alves r-u-b-e-m new
word a-l-v-e-s
and find his texts and buy his audio
books from whoever has them on sale it's
it'll really you know propel your
portuguese forward brazilian portuguese
of course
and he's full of wisdom and and a very
good attitude on education but he's as
he says nothing destroys the pleasure of
reading as much as having to analyze
answer questions about the text it's my
text i read it i'll form my
understanding of it i don't need to
answer to you and that's how i feel
other people may like to do that so
that's fine and dandy too it's a bit
like this issue of um
pronunciation and again i have someone
sent me a a video response to my video
where i said it's futile to think that
you're gonna sound like a native uh it's
it's fine to to use uh the native
and that uh you know uh
variant of the language that you find
most attractive or most useful or most
prestigious or whatever and use that as
your model and to try to imitate it is
fine but don't think you're going to
sound like a native
it's highly unlikely
and don't worry about it
and i also made the point that in my
experience the people i meet who speak
english well
uh
and who have an accent don't bother me
in the slightest people who have little
accent but misuse the language uh are a
much much bigger problem but the point
again there is
it's up to you if i'm learning the
language for myself
i don't care my goal is to communicate
to understand people understand me
uh
you know i community i can read i can
connect with the culture i'm happy
so i think it's very important that
everyone
identify what their goal is what is it
they want to do with this language if i
live in vancouver i'm not going to spend
a lot of time
talking to czech people
i may meet some people
i'm not going to make all my friends
check just so that i can speak czech i
have my friends i have a lot of
activities with people some of whom
speak foreign languages i don't choose
my friends based on whether they're
useful to me
in in the language that i'm learning
but
i can watch check movies i can read
check books i can go visit prague i can
get or other places in the czech
republic in fact i'm kind of thinking
now that i'd like to do the other
languages that were in the
austro-hungarian empire or the austrian
empire you know uh maybe learn up some
hungarian and
romanian and uh
polish and croatian and these were all
languages that were
in slovakia
but i guess it's pretty close to czech
that were part of that austro-hungarian
empire italian
uh but i may go back to korean first
because i have why because i play golf
with mr choi who's a very nice guy who
stumbles a bit in his english and would
probably humor me if i spoke to him in
korean so that's a motivation so
it all goes down to what and there my
motivation would be to talk to mr choi
so it all depends on what our motivation
is and we so that we learn languages for
ourselves
and our success depends on ourselves i
know michelle thomas in his tape says
that there's no bad student there's only
a bad teacher i don't believe that i
just don't believe that
other than
it may be that a very good teacher can
stimulate a learner can turn the learner
on to becoming motivated but the the
motivated learner learns and the
unmotivated learner
struggles and i think that's regardless
of the school you go to the teacher or
anything else so what really matters in
language learning is you so i think
people should really sit down and say
why am i learning this language what do
i want to achieve in this language and
then target and also
what do i like doing in this language
there's no point in subjecting yourself
to a method of learning that you don't
like
so find
a method of learning that suits your
tastes like i firmly believe that we
learn the same way that our brains
essentially learn the same way but we do
have different tastes and some people
like to read grammar explanations others
don't
some people only want to watch tv i
personally don't i prefer to listen and
read because i find it more dense in
terms of words and it's
for me it gets my imagi
imagination thinking about you know what
is the meaning in all this if it's
i do watch movies but
it's more as a reward or entertainment
not as a main
uh language learning tool but that's me
and so other people who like to watch tv
that's what they should do so i think
it's very important that what really
matters in language learning is you the
learner why am i learning this language
what do i like doing in the language
uh you know am i motivated how do i make
myself more motivated and when it comes
to being motivated
you know it's important to stay
motivated and therefore it's important
to
uh be satisfied with what you have
achieved like i'm reading check i'm
happy if i speak to yarda i stumble and
can hardly make myself understood i
don't let that ma that discourage me
it's very important once you have
achieved something to continue to enjoy
that and to give yourself credit for
what you have achieved rather than
worrying about what you have yet to
achieve the fact that there are things
that you can still strive for is a good
thing but when you fail or in your own
mind you failed or you forgot a word or
you didn't communicate as well as you
would have liked not a problem uh the
more you're sort of
unhappy about what you are unable to do
in the language the less well you will
learn because if you feel good about
your language studies
if you feel confident if you feel that
you're achieving something
um
you know we know
even in terms of that they measure what
goes on in the brain the brain's happy
if the brain achieves
a little better than what expected to
what it expected to achieve
uh it is motivated to learn more so
don't put obstacles in front of yourself
by uh
being frustrated that you don't speak
like a native or that you forget words
or that you continue to have trouble
with certain structures or certain
passages remain unclear to you that
doesn't matter focus
rather on what you have achieved it'll
make you happier and and you will learn
better so here again in terms of
attitude in terms of choosing what to
study in terms of motivating yourself
the key what matters most in language
learning is you the learner
thank you for listening bye for now